okay I really need someone to help me
out with this hopefully the media can
look into it I was doing some research
this morning actually I was researching
a marine biology which is how I spend my
free time and I came across a really
fascinating photograph take a look at
this as you can see in this footage
there's a bear holding machine gun
riding a great white shark now I've
heard of this phenomenon before I'm
pretty sure they mentioned it in a David
Attenborough documentary that I watched
a while ago but there's part of me as
I'm looking at that photo there's part
of me that thinks I got to be honest
there's a part of me wondering has this
been doctored in some way has it been
altered is there some funny business
going on here I don't know because on
one hand it makes perfect sense you
would expect bears and sharks to team up
it's why haven't they done it by now on
the other hand we live in the age of
fake news folks
and we just we need to face that fact
there are people out there you know
there are propagandists who want to
confuse us and sow discord so you can
never be too short and I'm hoping the
Washington Post or CNN or the New York
Times can look into this do some
fact-checking
just see you know run it up the flagpole
see see see what happens maybe call the
White House see what they have to say
because we need to get to the bottom of
this guys if there are shark riding
bears patrolling our oceans we need to
know and the other question we really
this is this is the question we need to
ask is whose side are they on of course
I asked for the media's help here
because they've really been on top of
the forgeries and photo shops this week
they've been doing a lot of
fact-checking
they spent all of yesterday as I'm sure
you've heard trying to figure out if
this photo of Trump giving the medal of
honor to a dog was photoshopped here's
that photo turns out pretty surprising
here turns out it was it was
photoshopped in fact it was photoshopped
by I'm ashamed to say it was
photoshopped by The Daily wire my own
company
my own company is trying to fool the
world into thinking that the White House
gives medals of honor to dogs
thank God the media exposed it thank God
the media exposed us and we're gonna
talk more about this issue today also
the on top of that issue we're gonna be
talking about some other things as well
the most disturbing drag queens story
our yets and this one really sets the
bar for better at a whole new level and
we're gonna talk about that several
several other things as well but first a
word from stamps calm you know when I
talk about stamps calm I always wonder
who in the world still goes to the post
office and why why would you do that
stamps calm brings the post office right
to you you don't need to go there
they'll bring it to you no need to
interrupt your work day or fight traffic
to get to the post office especially now
during the holidays that's when you
really want to avoid it because that's
when you're gonna get all the foot
traffic and and everything it's gonna be
crowded busy so stay away from that
that's why you need stamps calm anything
you can do with the post office you can
do at stamp stock up stamps comma
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money and and also gives you
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office stamps Tom brings all the
services of the US Post Office right to
your computer whether you're a small
business sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products even if
you're a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day whether it's a big or
small operation that you're running
stamps comm can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just drop it in your mailbox give
it to your mail carrier and that's it
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at the post office this year sign
up for stamps comm instead there's no
risk with my promo code wall should get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long term commitment or
contracts to get all that stuff if you
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Walsh that's stamps comm
enter Walsh stamps comm never go to the
post office again
okay hey by the way the picture of the
the bear riding the shark is actually
from a shower curtain that I found on
Amazon so pretty much the greatest
shower curtain of all time if you're
interested in picking one of those up go
go check that out now this thing with
the dog photo I think it all started
with Steve Herman of some news outlet or
another earnestly fact-checking the
obvious joke image of Trump giving a
medal of honor to a dog an image that
the brilliant Daily wire social media
team did in fact come up with after
after that and then Trump tweeted out
and I think Steve Herman was among the
first this is what he said I've
requested details from the White House
on this photo there was no such canine
event on today's POTUS schedule but
there is a Medal of Honor ceremony set
here for later today for an active duty
Green Beret there was no such canine
event Steve Herman says and then he goes
on he's got a long thread dealing with
this important issue it's photoshopped
acknowledges a White House official the
dog is not here at the White House yet
and then he goes on some more and he
starts retweeting someone else says why
the terrible Photoshop on top of
everything else someone else says this
is incredible it is despicable
additional words fail me wait it's
incredible it's despicable so this is
Steve Herman thinks it's dispel he
retweeted someone who said that it's
that this Photoshop is incredible and
despicable
what's despicable about it I don't even
I don't even understand the criticism
and then he retweets someone else
so what else saying well just the
president United States disseminating a
doctored image created by a right-wing
propaganda site hey you might hurt my
feelings
saying stuff like that about us so
that's Steve Herman then a bunch of
other news media outlets started
fact-checking my favorite headline was
from Twitter's trending section where
they do sort of their own
headlines and it said their headline was
this photo of Trump awarding hero hero
military dog is altered New York Times
reports then it continues on Wednesday
President Trump shared a photo of the
canine hero injured in the operation
that led to the death of Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi a New York Times report
pointed out the image appeared to be an
altered version of a 2017 Associated
Press photograph well thank God for that
report it's been altered folks in case
you were wondering because I had no idea
and then the actual New York Times
report is great the headline is Trump
tweets faked photo of hero dog at
getting a medal and the best part is
that there are two authors on this
article for the New York Times - they
put two reporters on this story okay you
check to see if any dogs have ever been
awarded the Medal of Honor and I'll
contact the White House we're gonna get
to the bottom of this if it's the last
thing we do and then a bunch of other
outlets got into the act and they
started they started actually calling up
the Medal of Honor recipient whose photo
was used to make the funny joke image of
the dog and they wanted to know if he
was offended or I should say they wanted
him to be offended and suggested to him
that he should be but he being a grown
man and a Medal of Honor recipient was
not offended at all and apparently
laughed and said he thought it was funny
and also said that that hey you know
dogs dogs are also part of the team and
so I got no problem with them being
recognized so he was cool about it but
the media insists that this is something
we should be upset about
they can't even explain why we should be
upset just that we should be because on
this one I have to tell you yeah I
really don't understand what the
criticism even is very often the media
will make criticisms of Donald Trump
that I think are frivolous are stupid or
I disagree with but I at least
understand conceptually what they're
saying in this case
even if I wanted to be offended by this
jokey funny Photoshop of a dog I don't I
can't figure out why I would be I
couldn't be offended even if I wanted to
be and this after three years the media
is still doing this they're still
embarrassing themselves by picking apart
every little thing Trump does it's on
top of everything else if you're a
left-wing media and you hate Donald
Trump and you want him gone
this is a really bad strategy it's of
course it's bad news reporting but we're
way past that they don't care about
actually reporting the news that's they
don't care about that so even from their
perspective perspective as as left-wing
propagandists this is just a terrible
strategy rather than focusing on the big
things that Trump does wrong we're gonna
[ __ ] we're not--we're to pick apart
every single little thing we're gonna
turn into headline news and then of
course if ever they do have a legitimate
criticism or a real thing a real a real
controversy no one pays attention to it
because well just the day before they
were going on about the dog all right
but I'm not gonna go on about it for
much longer than that so we'll move on
this is interesting Judicial Watch has a
report which in this report it shows it
shows how Planned Parenthood influences
Democratic politicians and and we all
know that Planned Parenthood does but it
turns out unsurprisingly that they
influenced Democratic politicians by
just telling them exactly what to say
verbatim so let me go to the Judicial
Watch report which you could find a
judicial watch.org says Judicial Watch
today released 115 pages of documents
from the office of governor of Virginia
Ralph Northam that show he received
abortion talking points directly from
Planned Parenthood these documents were
obtained as a result of two separate
Virginia Freedom
of Information Act requests the February
1st 2019 request was seeking all records
of communications of Northam or members
of his staff related to abortion women's
reproductive health and/or Virginia
House bill two two four nine one
Judicial Watch likewise requested
communication records between Northam
and his staff with Virginia state
representative Kathy Tran or her staff
so this was just summarizing rather than
reading the entire thing this was after
the statements that Northam made in the
infamous statements in that radio
interview where he was asked about what
a state lawmaker said a state
representative Kathy Tron had said about
how abortion should be legal up until
birth and Northam was asked about that
and infamously he went a step further
and strongly indicated that he thinks
that oh yeah abortion should be legal up
until birth and maybe even afterwards
because after the baby is born a
decision will be made or no that's his
actual words were I'll be up just to
remit just to remind us all what he said
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desires and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother strongly
indicating that the discussion is about
what are we gonna do with this kid kill
him or keep him so after that and that
blew up in his face PR nightmare and so
he gets in contact with the folks over
at Planned Parenthood asking them what
he should say in the future about
abortion and Alexis Rodgers responded in
an email from her PP AV it's a Planned
Parenthood org email account titled
top-line messages for Northam and these
are the talking points
she gave two Northam to say there is no
such thing as an abortion up until birth
making it a sit which is totally false
of course making a decision about
whether to continue a pregnancy is a
complex and personal decision
politicians have no place in this
process as a physician I know how
important it is to trust my patients and
for my patients to trust me
these are complicated medical decisions
that families deserve to make in private
without political interference and then
in a section of talking points titled
tricky Q&A Rodgers advises if possible
answer on background not for attribution
if a woman is in labor she couldn't and
wouldn't have an abortion and that
politicians and pro-life groups were
characterizing safe legal abortion in a
completely inaccurate and misleading way
okay so these are the the exact points
that Northam is being given and this is
what Planned Parenthood does with
Democrats just tell that this is what
you're supposed to say I think it's
really interesting there that this woman
from Planned Parenthood is telling him
what to say from his own perspective as
a doctor so she is saying she who is not
a doctor presumably is telling him what
to say from his perspective as a doctor
and it just goes to show how completely
empty these talking points are this is
all the reason why you go and try to get
talking points from someone is because
you don't want to engage on the issue
and so these are all ways of just
deflecting the very first talking point
that he's given is to simply deny what
he's just been talking about there is no
such thing as an abortion up until birth
well the only reason why this
controversy came up for him is that one
of his own state representatives was
advocating abortion up until birth
explicitly and so Planned Parenthood
solution is just to say oh yeah just
pretend you never said that pretend that
the thing that we are advocating doesn't
exist
that's how it works Planned Parenthood
is they are they own the Democrat Party
the Democrat Party is a prostitute for
Planned Parenthood essentially okay now
we go over to a report in the blaze
these drag queens story hours seem to be
getting progressively more disturbing
and this may be the worst one yet
reading now from a report in the blaze a
photograph shows a mini skirt wearing
drag queens story our performer with an
exposed crotch as children sit close by
according to a writer who attended the
event earlier this month at Ridgedale
library in Minnesota and then took the
photo and tailor noted in her
caffeinated thoughts piece that about 22
children ranging in age from infant to
toddler preschooler and elementary
schooler were in attendance along with
adults Taylor said performer sasha soda
who wore a pink miniskirt spiked heels
and a shirt with an exposed midriff
strode in suggestively passed the
children sitting down in a chair before
several preschool age girls with his
legs spread wide exposing his nylon
covered crotch in front of children
sitting at eye level we noticed that he
did this often while reading nervously
before the children and then here's a
picture of it I hate to show to you but
we need to know what we're dealing with
here and there's a picture of sasha
shota sasha soda flashing these children
she also mentions you could go to
caffeinated thoughts or go to the blaze
and read more of this but she talks
about should as you heard 20 some
children their parents are there she
mentioned that there were some dads
there who left now
she didn't say whether the dads left
with their kids I hope they did but the
first thing I think when I see this see
stuff like this is what why isn't any
father why do we why haven't we seen a
case yet where a father steps up
and confronts one of these people for
what they're doing on the spot if you've
got a guy sitting down in a miniskirt
flashing children that would be a good
time as a father not just to leave
meekly and sneak out the back but to
stand up and say this is not acceptable
this isn't gonna happen you need to get
up and get the hell out of here
why isn't that happening now where are
the parents in this and even worse of
course in many of these cases you have
parents who are not only do they not
leave but they stay there and they watch
approvingly and they smile and nod and
clap along and it's absolutely
disgusting so for me this this goes back
first and foremost of the parents these
you know libraries libraries libraries
could have these drag queen story hours
where they invite cross-dressing men to
come and flash children you know if if
they did that and nobody showed up then
it wouldn't be a problem this is only a
problem the only reason why it's an
issue is because parents are choosing to
put their children in the car and drive
to these events so for me this goes back
to the parents yeah the libraries it's
insane for libraries especially
tax-funded libraries to be using tax
funds to put on these perverse
disgusting
events that is despicable and they
shouldn't be doing it but it would be a
moot point if all the parents in the
area were real parents and just refused
to bring their kids because then you
would just have a cross-dressing man
sitting alone
sadly in a room by himself reading a
story to himself that's what it should
be
by the way Chad Felix green over at the
Federalist he has a he wrote a piece on
this on this incident as well and he
reports that this drag queen is a quote
provocative adult entertainer who
usually performs at gay nightclubs so
this is not someone who's just in the
business of putting on women's clothes
to go and read to children as weird as
that is already this is someone who
according to Chad Felix created
Federalist this is someone who is what
he normally does is he goes and he
dresses and he and he dances for adult
gay men at gay nightclubs this is an
adult entertainer that this library has
called up and said hey would you put on
one of those outfits one of those skimpy
outfits and come and read to some kids
for us and then I guess they put a they
they post it on the bulletin board in
the library and parents walk by and they
see they say oh that looks that sounds
great
yes of a cross-dressing man reading the
kids I got to get my kids in for this
that's a it's mind-boggling it really is
okay before we get to emails I should
say
happy Halloween you know I'm a bee I'm a
big fan of Halloween I get I get really
excited for it in fact here's a photo of
me a couple nights ago at a trunk or
Treat event with the kids at our church
as you can see I'm very very excited and
happy and thrilled to be there you just
see the enthusiasm on my face and you
can also see my quintessential dad
outfit and I didn't even realize until
now as I look at that photo that I am
officially a middle-aged man the only
thing I'm missing with that outfit is is
I guess the new all-white New Balance
sneakers and then well sort of knock off
New Balance sneakers that I bought at
Target and then maybe a fanny pack those
are the only two things missing and then
I am I'm full on dad but I'll tell you
what my lack of inside excitement was
it's dark there are a million kids
running around you know what a
trunk-or-treat thing is it's like people
you go to a parking lot and people show
up and they park their cars
then you stand there with candy and you
just walk to each car in the parking lot
to get candy so I've got my three kids
I'm trying to keep track of them they're
running in 19 different directions at
once because you know that something
kids can do kids are like who's the blue
guy and watchman who can multiply
himself and go with that that's that's
kind of what kids can do they can
multiply themselves and go in multiple
directions at once so I'm trying to keep
track of that it's dark there are all
these other kids there they're a bunch
of cards probably probably probably
literally six thousand cars with with
candy and and none of the kids even say
trick-or-treat anymore that's not a
thing anymore you just walk up demanding
the candy with your bucket out they get
the candy very businesslike and then
they go to the next one and they go to
the other and it's just total mayhem the
thing that annoyed me the most though is
that I knew we're gonna have to do this
all over again we're gonna do it tonight
because what I've discovered as a parent
is that these days you can't just have
one holiday celebration every holiday is
celebrated five or six times you've got
trunk-or-treat at the church
you've got the Halloween party at school
you've got a Halloween thing somewhere
else and then you got Halloween on
Halloween and then maybe you've got a
second Halloween after Halloween and
then Christmas comes and there's there's
there's Christmas on Christmas and then
Christmas with the grandparents and
Christmas or the other grandparents and
Christmas with the other family who
didn't show up for the other seven
Christmases and Christmas parties and by
the end of it my kids have acquired this
truckload of new toys 95% of which
they'll be sick of by next Tuesday
back in my day damn it we had one
holiday okay the whole year that's it my
parents said to me what holiday do you
want to celebrate this this year you
want to do Christmas you want to do your
birthday you want to do Halloween
because you only get one and if we chose
Halloween we had to walk 10 miles in
between each house without shoes on in
flooded streets and we didn't get candy
we gave them candy we passed out the
candy and we liked it damn it kids these
days have no idea what it was like in
the 90s which is why I get away with
making up crap about it
go to emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
Matt while showed um I like I'm is that
I don't know if that's just something
with my family or or if this is just how
it is now we're at where you there are
you celebrate each holiday the sixty
times because it really wasn't what I
did as a kid but it seems to be that's
the trend now or maybe it's just me I
don't know well really it's not me it's
my wife who insists that you know each
holiday must be celebrated twelve or
thirteen different times okay from Simon
this says it says dear great bearded one
I have proudly worn a beard for a long
time but last night shaved it off into
mutton shops to look more like Jake
blues John Belushi for my Halloween
costume I felt no one would understand
the costume if I had the beard now the
morning after I see my naked face and I
am ashamed wondering if I have sinned
against God and against my future leader
I would appreciate some guidance or
guidance on this matter where my actions
appropriate Simon first of all I think
you know the answer to the question the
guilt that you're feeling should tell
you everything you need to know let me
ask you something if you wanted to dress
up as an injured Civil War soldier would
you cut your arm off to sell the costume
if you wanted to be the headless
horseman would you cut your head off if
you were going as Ray Charles would you
blind yourself and hey you were going as
John Belushi did you did you gain a
hundred pounds you know where you were
you were you method acting as far as
that goes if the answer is no to all of
these questions then you tell me why it
was necessary to shave your beard so no
your actions were not appropriate they
were despicable and a betrayal of the
bearded community you sir are a traitor
and a scoundrel and may you feel the
wrath of God in this life in the next
but thanks for the email from Beth says
hi Matt what's your take on Halloween
some of my friends feel strongly that
it's a pagan holiday and Christians
shouldn't celebrate it yes now we do the
annual is Halloween pagan thing it's the
every year we have to talk about
I appreciate Beth because this has to be
our our annual discussion about that no
I don't think that that Halloween is
pagan
I think the anti Halloween stuff among
Christians is frankly silly of course
they're free to make their own decisions
of in their own families about whether
they want to celebrate Halloween or not
but as a matter of history no Halloween
is not pagan actually at its root it's
it's a very Christian holiday Halloween
All Hallows Eve All Saint's Eve tomorrow
is All Saints Day
that's the roots of the holiday now can
you trace certain aspects of the modern
traditions associated with Halloween
back to quote pagan cultures a long time
ago I mean sure probably but you can do
that with every holiday and probably
every tradition you can think of
probably you could trace some of the
associated customs back to quote pagan
civilizations because you go back far
enough into the past and almost everyone
was a pagan certainly all of the major
civilizations were pagan you know the
Greeks the Romans the Egyptians so on
and so forth so that's part of our human
heritage and therefore certain aspects
of that past some parts of our
traditions have carried over and and so
what you know they don't have any pagan
meaning anymore birthdays birthdays are
pagan I don't know if people knew this I
think that Jehovah's Witnesses know this
I think this is why they don't celebrate
birthdays I'm pretty sure about that
they well I know they don't celebrate
birthdays I'm not really sure why but
maybe that's the reason they say well
it's pagan and and that's actually true
that pagan cultures were the first to
celebrate birthdays I think it was I
think that really you trace it back to
the Egyptians don't quote me on this I'm
pretty sure google it to check to check
but I'm pretty sure that birthdays you
chased back to the Egyptians and many of
the things like birthday candles and so
on originally those were expressly
religious things
religious symbolism was a pagan
religious celebration
now Judaism in ancient times they did
mark certain special birthdays but there
was no tradition of celebrating every
single birthday in Judaism which is you
know we trace our own religious heritage
back to that and and so if you want to
go back far enough you say well
birthdays were not really a Jewish thing
they're not a Christian thing they were
a pagan thing but I ask you when we
celebrate birthdays are we there for
worshipping pagan gods I mean obviously
not just because it's something that
originates with paganism doesn't mean
that it still has pagan intent or pagan
content pagans also wore pants does that
mean we shouldn't wear pants are we are
we idol-worshipping when we're parent
wear pants it gets absurd after a while
but all of this is irrelevant anyway
because Halloween is in practice in
reality actually a very modern holiday
all of this history which as I said
really begins in Christianity with with
certain of its associated traditions
perhaps going back to paganism but all
that is academic because Halloween as it
has become today is a modern commercial
invention Halloween the type that we
celebrate today has very little
resemblance to anything that anyone did
back in ancient times whether
monotheistic or polytheistic so really
it is just it's it's a it's a modern
thing that we do it's just a silly
tradition it's not a big deal now if
you're telling me you don't do Halloween
just because it's a hassle you don't
feel like dealing with it then I'm with
you because that I totally understand
but if you're telling me that you're
worried that all the people who are
celebrating Halloween are sort of
accidentally worshipping pagan gods or
something then I have to say that I find
that to be a little bit ridiculous this
is from Mitchell says after reflective
of LGBTQ History Month a particular idea
kept pestering me the search for a
non-binary pronoun the currently
prevailing notion is they then but this
solution fails grammatically we need a
singular pronoun and this brings me to
what I call the it's argument the
English language already has a
genderless pronoun it but certainly
referring to another person as an it
would be deemed rude and downright
dehumanizing which is correct but why we
for the most part used the word it's to
describe subjects or objects that are
not men or women
ie inanimate or animals for example if
you were to pay a compliment to a parent
of a baby and didn't know the gender you
wouldn't call the baby in it you would
just call the baby a baby however you
wouldn't be so careful with regards to a
person's car or pet goldfish or even dog
if the starting position of a non-binary
person is I am NOT a man and I am also
not a woman then they have
coincidentally put themselves in the
same group as inanimate objects and
animals thus dehumanizing themselves I
submit that about that by rejecting it
as a sufficient pronoun on the grounds
that it is dehumanizing
they are ceding the idea that being a
man a woman is an integral part of the
human condition I'm a longtime viewer
first time in a land I would love to
hear your thoughts on this argument
doesn't hold water or could it be
improved I would say it does hold water
I don't think I can't improve on it I
think you're exactly right and I think
I'm not even gonna add to it I think I
think you you you have you have landed
on something on an important insight
here that when you get rid of the he or
she I think the people who do that
realize that it's kind of dehumanizing
so they're trying to come up with a
pronoun that isn't he or she but that
also isn't dehumanizing and they have a
lot of difficulty doing it which is one
of the reasons we talked a few weeks ago
about all the made-up pronouns now
because they're just they yeah they're
trying to avoid the most obvious thing
would be it but nobody wants to be in it
for good reason and so yeah maybe that
should make you think that okay well so
maybe it is integral to the human person
to be a he or she and I should just
stick with that because I am a human
being I'm not an it
this is from Antonio says hi Matt I
would like I hope you'll be supreme
dictator one day I would like to ask you
10 yes/no questions I think that if the
questions are correct you've correctly
formulated this interviewing meThe
is very interesting let's see if you can
give me ten yes no one should abortion
be illegal yes that was an easy one too
should sex change operations be illegal
yes three were the many accusers of
Kavanagh lying yes
four should Jesse Smollett go to jail
yes five is Islam a religion of peace no
six will you send your children to
university i reaiiy can't that with that
one I can't do yes or no because its
first of all it's not gonna be totally
up to me so that what I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna have to do nad on that one not
applicable at the moment I'm not sure
seven would you like to know the day of
your death no eight would you take a
pill that would guarantee eternal life
no your talk about eternal mortal life
well mortal and I guess it's not because
eternal but but eternal life in this
world where I'm just living in this
physical body forever there are a lot of
problems there I mean for instance
eventually the the the earth itself is
will be destroyed I mean eventually our
entire solar eventually our whole galaxy
will be destroyed and then if I'm still
around I'll just I'll just be floating
around in space for eternity that sounds
horrifying nine will trump be reelected
I'll say yes if the left and the media
the Democrats continue on their current
trajectory and continue with their
current strategy then I would say yes he
will be ten is feminism a cancer of
Western society yes well I was a fun
exercise I don't know I wish you
challenged me a little bit more with yes
or no questions most of those were
pretty easy so what I would say Antonio
is maybe try again I mean really
challenge me give me something hard here
but thanks everybody for watching and
hope you have a nice Halloween of fun
Halloween if that's even possible and
I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]